very much well you know it's the middle
of december and uh
we're almost into new year i was
thinking about speaking today on the
topic maybe uh
you know when you you when you're in a
gang like the gang life and the gang
style you know there's a lot of things
that come with it you know i mean
there's women
you know there's money you know there's
guns you know there's
liars manipulators you got all types of
them you know and
the thing that i wanted to talk about
today was you know
has a lot to do with the drug trade you
know i'm not gonna put no names out
there or any people or where they're at
and what kind of drugs
nothing like that but i'm not gonna sit
here and tell you that i haven't used
drugs
i've tried every drug you can imagine
you know i mean i've tried them i've
slammed i've drank i've smoked snorted
you know i tried them all and
there's only one or two that really
stuck around
for a while all the rest went like
marijuana that came and went you know
cocaine came and went
crystal meth came and went but the hard
one that didn't leave was heroin you
know
and heroin catches you up so bad that
you know
you hear guys say oh let's sell their
own mama for it i have seen dudes
that'll sell anything they have you know
i ran into people that
will give you the title to their car you
know let you live in their house you
know
one time we ran into this guy you know
and i remember selling him a 20 on the
corner one time it was in my hood i was
sounding a little dope
this dude came about a 20 you know i
mean i had never seen him before
but i had heard through the grapevine
that the dude had money you know
so i followed him around the corner to
see what he got in and he got in a
pretty nice car he got in one of those
chrysler 300s you know but it was really
nice
and i'm thinking why is this dude only
buying a 20 when he's driving a brand
new car you know
but as i got to meet the guy i found out
why you know i mean who this guy was was
he was the major drug dealer for
like three cities around us and remember
he only came about a 20 off me so i was
like
when i found out about him i was like
why would this guy only come and buy a
20
and not buy a big issue when he has a
lot of money well what he was doing was
he had his feelers out there i mean he
had his filters out there he wanted to
know
who were the main ones from the hood who
moved the most dope who had the most
juice you know i mean and this dude he
was pretty good you know i mean
he used to come and he bought another 20
the next day he came again he started
asking about how much was an eight ball
how much was an ounce you know i mean i
didn't give him no numbers at that time
because
i really didn't trust the guy you know i
mean and being in the dope game you know
you got to be careful because
you know some guys will tell you they
got a mountain full of dope
and all they got is a pocketful another
fool will tell you he got a pocket full
of dope
and he's sitting on a mountain this dude
i'm speaking of you know
i'm friends with him today you know i
mean and he still does the same thing
now the first thing he told me about
well about about the drug trade was
your clientele you know what i'm saying
and this dude he didn't sell to nobody
under a certain age
i think it was 35 40. he sold to nobody
under that age and
at first i was like whoa wait up i'm
like 32
you know and the dude don't sell to
anybody over 35 why is he selling to me
well i studied the guy you know i did my
homework on the dude and
i found out that the dude moved a lot of
[ __ ] dope
but he never put his business out there
but the one thing he did do was
he did a lot of tests you know with dope
with money you know
and as through meeting him i noticed
that
he was picking certain people to deal
his dope
he had like he wanted two women and
three men you know and this dude he went
he had did like 15 years in in
in jail and um he had buried some [ __ ]
he had put it away in the ground in the
back
in the backyard of his mother's house
and this dude had been gone for like
i'd say maybe two and a half years and i
had heard about him when i was when i
met him the first time
when he when i told him that 20 he had
got busted like about a year later
but through that year he used to come
and he used to
ask a lot of questions and i was like
man i used to be very leery of a person
who asked a lot of questions
because either dude's a cop he's either
writing some type of book or doing some
documentary or doing writing anything
about the hood or he's either trying to
you know get some type of movie some
type of skit or he just knows a
[ __ ]
and i was behind this dude and i would
follow this guy
wherever he would go because i wanted to
know exactly who this dude was
now i followed him the first time he
went to this expensive ass
hotel he was at and i watched this dude
from the car me and my homie we had a g
right here watches do with binoculars we
watched this dude for a while you know
and all he had was a woman going women
going in and out
and i wanted to know who this fool was
and like i said today he's one of my
best friends you know but
at that time i was really really leery
of this guy because
he used to come in by dope and he used
to ask questions and his questions
weren't
the regular questions his questions were
more or less like well how long's that
guy been from the hood or how long has
he been doing it out here
and that right there made me pretty
leery of the guy now
i thought that the guy was by himself i
didn't know that the guy had one of my
homies already working for him one of my
home girls working for him
and he was asking them about me so i'm
out there doing my thing i'm out there
gang banging and the drug trade i didn't
really want no part of it because
i've seen a lot of things that drugs do
to people i've seen a lot of my older
homegirls
they wouldn't even take care of their
kids you know i mean they would leave
their house all [ __ ] dirty
you know what i mean the only time they
they would be happy is when they were
getting paid on the first or the 15th
that's when offer used to come in you
know those are like the favorite days
you know
and um he had one of my homegirls and i
remember from seeing her
from slamming on the corner i seen her
driving an escalade
a nice ass apartment and i didn't see
nothing in between
so i was wondering how did my homegirl
go from here and get up here
well what that dude actually did was he
got a hold of my homegirl he sat her
down
and he offered her do you want this or
do you want to stay with this
well my homegirl she she rised quick
because my hunger was the type of woman
that
she would do business with you but if
you did it wrong one time she would
never do business with you again
now she had got this from this guy this
guy i was telling you about she had got
these
certain rules that he had because he
didn't break them even for himself
now this dude was about 28 years old and
man he had nice cars he had a cadillac
he had a suburban you know we had some
nice sized cars
this was after i found out about him now
the reason i move this up is because
it's the drug trade
stuff can seem this way but it's
actually
the complete opposite you know when the
dude came at me the first time he tells
me uh
hey man how much do you get for an ounce
of weed he started off with weed so i
said well
right now they're going 50 or 60 dollars
at that time it tells me what if i give
them to you for 25
i was like 25 an hour that's four ounces
for every 100.
i'm thinking in my head wait there has
to be a catch with this because you
remember
i'm sharing this with the people that
haven't got involved with drugs
and i hope you don't get involved but if
you do get involved i'm just giving you
a few pointers on
not who sings it or who is it no like
like that i'm trying to give you
pointers on
be careful because there's a lot of good
times with drugs
but then there's a lot of bad times with
drugs you know and if you get involved
with them
you have to make certain rules in your
rule book because
you have to keep them there you know
guys will tell you anything i've had
[ __ ] come on the street and
tell me man
you know what i mean uh look man i got
this gold ring and this gold chain and i
mean they look like they were really
gold
and i ended up giving like 100 bucks
worth of dope from then when i went to
check them out they were fake
but yet the guy cruised up with him
driving his wife sitting crying in
shotgun seat
his kids in the back seat in some car
seats and they're crying and dude's
telling me he needs help with some money
because he has to drive somewhere and
take his wife and kids that they're on
the streets and
i felt bad for him but at that moment my
girlfriend that was with me tells me
don't give him [ __ ] he's lying but from
what i was seeing the dude was telling
me what was happening and zola was
crying
and shaking her head no and then his
kids were in the back seat crying so
i fell for the guy i ended up giving him
like a hundred bucks
and some dope and the fool wasn't
hurting at
all at all you know that reminds me of
like three months ago
i was over here talking to this dude he
was on a bike all tore up
he goes down the street parks his bike
in a tent
takes off that coat has a nice shirt
under takes off those sweats
nice pants under a pair of shorts he had
nice pair of shorts under
took his sweats off and had some nice
shoes and jumped into a bmw
now why i'm saying this is because
there's actually people that come over
here
downtown and they'll park their car on
one block
put some raggedy clothes on come to the
next corner
get their sling on for maybe five six
hours and then
go back to their car get in it and leave
now people do this a lot you know people
do this a lot and
i've only learned this through the time
doing drugs and being around drugs
i've only learned that drugs don't give
a [ __ ] how old you are
they don't give a [ __ ] who you are you
don't give a [ __ ]
man or woman child or adult
drugs have no conscience they have
they'll
they'll you give it to anybody anybody
does it i ran into this guy the other
day he was like about
14 years old and i ran into him buying
heroin
and it struck me hard because
you could tell the guy was only 13 14
years old and he had rigs on him
he was hitting dude in the neck and i
was like man this guy's like 13 14.
where in the [ __ ] did he learn how to
poke somebody in the neck or draw a
blood
what do you learn all this so lo and
behold i sat down with a guy
and this was dude's nephew the guy that
was telling you about in the beginning
the big dude that was doing big things
this was his nephew way at the bottom
slamming heroin 13 14 years old and
you know to these youngsters out there i
give you a solemn advice not to touch it
because once you touch it it's very hard
to put down
it's not hard to put down because you
can just say i don't want to do it
anymore no that's not
it once you do it for so long and it
catches ahold of you
it's like they call it the monkey he
grabs on your back
and he's [ __ ] hard to get off he's
hard to get off oh they got programs
they got methadone
they got sober living they got uh the
other one where they where they uh
when they take you for a week or so and
they bring you all the way down to where
you got to take anything anymore
you know a lot of it is helpful but a
lot of it is a crock of [ __ ]
you know a lot of it you got people in
their counselors that are telling you
what it is to do heroin and they've
never even slammed and they've never
even picked up
a dime to get high on but yet they're
telling you how
to kick heroin the only one i would
listen to was a person who already used
heroin before
you know me not nobody who hasn't used
it you know because those people are
more or less
textbook smart they read out of what
other people have written down
in their experiences and then those
people go off it i would rather learn
from a person
that has already been on drugs has
already been strung out
and been to that point where nothing
else matters
you know when you're struggling on
heroin nothing else matters except
your next high yeah i'm not saying that
guys don't have kids and there's not
guys that are functioning heroic acts
because i ran into them
where they got their own home they got a
nice job they got their kids there they
got their wife
but basically i'm heroin they're
functioning heroin users and i applaud
them because
it's really really hard to get a life
going and to get a heroin habit at the
same time
i'm speaking from experience i'm not
speaking from something i
heard or read in a book no you know i've
been to the point where
i had money but money wasn't the thing
you can have the money but if you ain't
got the dope
you ain't going nowhere you don't mean
and i've been to the point where
i've been to the top where you know
you're hired you know you you're up
there slinging big on a nice car
a nice house a big flat screen tv
everything in your home
but then i'm sitting in front of the tv
and i'm wondering
why i'm not supposed to
have it like this i would tell myself
that i wasn't supposed to have a screen
tv
a nice car a nice woman a nice bike
whatever i had
i wasn't supposed to have nice things so
i was setting myself up
from the beginning because i didn't feel
that i could be successful that's how i
felt i actually felt that i could be
successful so
when i did sit in there with my nice ass
tv in my nicest apartment
in the back of my mind my conscience
would tell me i didn't
i wasn't supposed to have it like this
and a lot of us do that you know i mean
when you get on drugs a lot of times you
tell yourself
well i'm not supposed to have it like
this you know i mean that's kind of a
[ __ ] up way of thinking because
you stunt your growth no matter what
you're going in whether you're
doing less dope making more money making
less money
uh cutting down your clientele whatever
it is you know
uh in the back of your mind you always
have that in your subconscious that
you are not supposed to have it like
this and i told myself that not once
but several times behind drugs you know
one time i had my own car
i had a nicest apartment a nice ass
[ __ ] job
and i remember going down the 10 freeway
and i was just about to hit
like uh was it i was just about to hit
like martin luther king or something
going to downtown
while i was still like there south
central and i just pulled over to the
side of the freeway
turned my car off turned the radio off
and i was just sitting there
and i was asking myself why
was i right here in life i wasn't
supposed to be right here
in this in this part of life i'm not
saying i was supposed to be right there
with the drug trade or the money no i'm
talking about me
just living comfortable period i wasn't
supposed to
live in that fashion i wasn't supposed
to have those nice things
because i guess it was because most of
the money
came from dealing drugs so i bought this
but i didn't buy it like my grandfather
or my uncle did it
with the sweat off their bra and off
their back no i did it where
i just had to stand in the corner and
switch money for dope
you know and i learned that it didn't
matter who
came and bought the dope from you
because i used to sell to a guy that
worked at the bank
he was the manager bank manager and he
used to come and buy crystal meth for me
and he worked for five seven days a week
but he used to come and buy men for me
and this dude used to come in a suit
nice as close and i used to be like
where the [ __ ] does this do work at so
when i finally
seen him i didn't ask him i seen him at
the bank
he see me real quick and he got kind of
nervous but i told him one trip
i ain't going to say [ __ ] but then after
i see him at the bank
i see him outside you know down the way
he was buying some dope and i told him
hey you know what do you do at that bank
you know
because i was interested dude works at a
bank it might dope off me you know
of course i'm interested maybe we can do
something you know but at the same time
i just wanted to know the caliber of men
that this guy was this dude had
education
he had been to college he was working as
a bank manager had a nice wife children
but he had tasted some of that black
dragon that heroin
and it got the best of him now i
remember seeing him
doing duel away right in front of me at
first she started
getting a piece of heroin and just
sticking it in his nose that's all he
did he just stuck a piece in his nose
and he just let it drain all day then he
went from that
to squirting it in his nose then he went
from squirting in his nose he tried
something different
he actually got like a patch he put the
heroin on there then he would put it on
his arm
and he would go jogging whatever working
out and he said that
the heron was soaked into his pores so
he went from there
then the last time i seen him he was
drawing it up in a rig
but when he drew it up in the rig i
noticed that he no longer wore his nice
attire
he didn't have his hair cut the right
way he didn't look like he was working
in the bank anymore so i had to ask him
you know hey what happened you don't
work in the bank anymore
no well he got fired because somebody
was missing and
they blamed him you know and if he was
joe real quick he got out and
i'm looking at this dude from now from
day one i seen him when he would have
some nice ass clothes and i said job to
the point now where
he's about to jump on a bike that's flat
you don't have nice clothes
but yet this is what heroin did to him
you know what i mean
he thought in the beginning he told me
that it was going to be all funny games
and he was going to be able to feel good
feel no pain
never get sick because that's what
heroin does you don't feel pain
you never get a cold or flu i i forgot
what a colder flu felt like
when i was getting high in hearing for
like three years straight i never got
sick one time
people were all around me sneezing and
coughing and i wouldn't have to wear a
mask or i wouldn't have to cover myself
it was just that some way heroin
blocked off not just that but it blocked
off getting sick
i mean i even noticed to the point where
i couldn't even walk down the street and
walk through a patch of roses
i wouldn't even smell the roses when
everybody else walked through there
you could smell the roses heroin blocks
off
your sort your smell your sense of smell
you can still smell something bad or
something very strong
but i'm talking about just walking down
the street you know you got those purple
trees
that grow and you can smell that that
purple smell you know you smell it i
used to smell like my grandmother's
house
but the other day i'm bringing this up
because the other day i walked under
those trees
and i caught a little scent of what i
was actually supposed to be
taking in and breathing getting the
actual smell
but i read up on it and it states that
heroin
takes that part of your senses out now
that's just that one i'm not saying they
don't take anything
else away but these are for the people
that haven't used heroin or that already
started using
using it you know that thing is going to
be around your life for a very very long
time
let me tell you i have did it stopped
did it stop
i mean i stopped completely for five
years didn't even take an aspirin
not even an aspirin i wanted no drugs in
my body no aspirin tylenol weed
nothing and to be honest with you those
five years
i could say were probably the best five
years of my life because drugs were not
a part of me
you know i had that nice car that i paid
the loan every every
every month i had that nice three
bedroom apartment by myself
you know i mean i had nice clothes you
know uh
the women they were still kind of the
same but
different friends you know i mean i had
different friends i didn't run with the
same crowd
and i didn't think that i was i was any
better but i noticed
at times if i seen you on the streets
and you were getting high
i would just say here and i would leave
i would avoid you
but if you weren't getting high i would
keep you on part of my team and this is
you know and my team
guys that didn't get high i remember one
time my cousin asked me
when i was deep into the game my cousin
asked me hey man
let me get a part of that action you
know and i told him do you ask him do
you get hired
and he's like yeah i said well then here
you know you can't get a part of this
action
he threw that in my face like about
three years ago hey remember when i
asked you
if i could work with you and you said if
i get high that i had no part of it
i said yeah i had to apologize because i
didn't feel that
i was any better than anyone that used
drugs i just didn't want anybody around
me that used them because
i know me if i seen it and it was the
right time i would do it and then from
that point on
it would just be a roller coaster ride i
couldn't just
use it and stop use it and stop that
wasn't me i had to use it buy more use
it by more and then sell it
to buy more you know that was my thing
and when my cousin do that in my face
i kind of felt guilty and kind of bad
because
i was at the same position he was at
many times
and i remember when i had asked people
the same thing and they shot me down
where they were shooting me down for the
same reason that i shot my cousin down
just recently i have a homie that he
does
skits and he does parts in hollywood he
works for suspect entertainment
now that's his whole hook up there
that's all him
and i've heard them other homies that he
was getting guys you know to do you know
come out of movies and do different [ __ ]
and i thought man you know maybe i could
get a piece of that action maybe i can
you know
put my face on the screen and you know
speak to somebody but when i got in my
homie
that was the first question he asked me
that was the first question
he saw do you get hired and i was going
to tell him no
but i wouldn't be able to hide it in
front of him because he doesn't get high
himself he never has
in all the years i've known him he's
been through my in my hood since i was a
kid he's been a kid
he's never ever used drugs that wasn't
his thing but when he asked me that
question if i use drugs
because i asked him about you know his
movie thing when he asked me that i was
gonna lie to him and tell him no i don't
[ __ ] around
but it would have been too hard because
he would have found out i was [ __ ]
around then i would have been deep in
this
deep enough spot with him and he's the
type of individual that you don't want
to get in no
kind of situation with he's just that
type of [ __ ] now
when he asked me that i told him yeah i
get high
he said well let me know when you don't
get high anymore and you could come work
for me
now i've seen his skits i've seen parts
on music videos that he
did you know and he's pretty good you
know i also seen him speak for 30
minutes on eyewitness news they had this
kind of half an hour special
and he was on there i also seen this
little uh like movie he did on youtube
and he's pretty good you know what i
mean
i like his stuff and i would never hate
him my homie but the only thing
is that if you get high you can't be no
part
of him and it's kind of hard for me to
believe that every individual i see on
that screen with him
they all don't get high that that's just
hard for me to believe but
to each his own you know and that's a
part of the drug game that
if you're getting high if i wouldn't
have been getting high i probably would
have had action with him
i probably would have been making big
money but yet i chose to get high
because in the beginning when i first
started getting high oh it was fun
prison was fun jail was fun everything
was fun
but now that i got older a lot of it's a
crock of [ __ ]
i mean i go to jail now and i don't see
one person that i know from jail not one
guy
before when i used to go to jail oh man
i knew everybody in there i know
everybody from the streets from
different parts of jail
i knew all gang of guys in there now i
go in there and i don't know a soul in
there
but i got this 18 year old kid telling
me to be quiet
not in that fashion but more or less you
know shut it down
put it on quiet and that means shut up
in other words and
i know the 18 year old kid ain't been
nowhere he got a deep ass voice with a
little ass body
but he's that man in that seat
and for me to sit back and just allow
him to
dictate my program when he hasn't even
been to a real program the guy hasn't
been to her not saying he's a bad guy
but
i think always somebody who has a seat
of authority
should have some type of knowledge of
what he's doing you know i mean and
i share that with the people that are
going to get involved in drugs because
when you get involved in drugs there's
one thing that's going to come for sure
jail you know i find rsv that there's
someone out there that can sell gang of
drugs and not get higher than themselves
you know what i mean it's hard to
believe because i've seen every kind of
drug dealer
imaginable dude on the corner
i seen a dude in it we called it the
mini mansion this fool actually had
white house pillars in front of his
house you know what i mean
this guy was a straight white guy no
tattoos
no hardness to his look but in reality
he was a stone [ __ ] solid ass
[ __ ] he didn't take [ __ ] from
nobody
but his appearance threw you off you
think i'll rob this guy
no he'd be the last [ __ ] you
want to rob you know what i mean his
house was nice i mean
he had white house pillars in the front
he had a pool table in his den
you know this dude had it going on and
all he used to do
was pick up something from somewhere and
drop it off somewhere else he never ever
touched anything he never ever
lined anything up or so not he that's
all he did and
you know that type of drug dealer you
know my grandfather told me one time
do you think you're a drunk dealer you
where's your truck
load of dope at when you roll up with a
truck semi full of drugs
then i'll say you're a drug dealer
because a real drug dealer has a [ __ ]
mansion
has a [ __ ] army with them and has
truckloads of dope
a guy that's slinging 50s or 100s on the
street he's not a gold dealer he's just
what you call a connection
you know and there's a difference
between the between being the connection
and being the main dough dealer there's
a big big difference
if you want to call yourself a dope
dealer and you're balling well then you
have to drive with samurai up
fully or dope and then you're bawling
i'll actually say you're bawling
you know my little brother used to
always ask me when he's to sell dope and
we're in the gang and she used to ask me
am i volume blowing my volume and i
should tell him nah
nah and then one time he asked me hey am
i balling and i said look
you'll be bawling when i see you turn
that corner
in a hummer three months later
i'm in my head kicking it and the hummer
turns the corner
and my little brother gets off it he
comes around and he tells me what's up
bro
am i balling and i told him yeah yeah
now now yeah
you could say your ball you know he was
driving a hummer you know and my brother
is only a year younger than me
but he approached it in a different way
you know i mean he approaches things
in his own fashion you know he wants no
part of anybody don't want to get
involved with nobody it's just him
pay his dues but he always keeps to
himself you know meaning
he's been in jail so many times being
caught with so many guns but never a
clip
and i didn't know that you can get
caught with a gun if you don't get
caught with the clip they'll let you out
the next day
but if you get caught with the clip they
ain't gonna let you out in a while i
barely found this out you know but that
was just
you know asking information you don't
mean about different [ __ ] you know
because
if your lifestyle is a certain way my
best advice is
find out what comes with that type of
lifestyle
because like i said with drugs when it
comes heartache and pain
suffering you know what i mean sometimes
you're so [ __ ]
hooked on it that you want it so bad
that you go to desperate measures
you know you got with all due respect
you got women out here
man that southern south's not three
blocks away from where i kick it at
and i've always wondered in my mind
i understand how a prostitute does it
but what happens if the
ugliest sickest smelliest person comes
and has a gang of money and wants to
sleep with you
and you got to sleep with them for that
money
i couldn't lower my standards that low
and do that and still feel comfortable
with myself
and i asked the prostitutes that
question before what happens if this big
old fat greasy [ __ ] comes with
pimples on his back and he wants you to
kiss me
what do you do and she told me that
you just do what you got to do and i was
like i can't understand that
you don't mean because at that point i
would say wait up man i'm not [ __ ]
putting my hands on this person
not saying anything everybody's earlier
everybody's handsome as [ __ ] i'm just
saying
there is a certain line that i don't
cross
in the young department that's just the
way it is you know i mean but
when i asked these prostitutes on the
streets when i was dealing drugs
that's what they told me that you just
got to do what you got to do you know
and i didn't understand that
you know prostitution ain't like selling
drugs you're selling your body
not something you can have in your hand
you know what i mean and i mean i'm
slang for marijuana
cocaine heroin guns i'm slaying it all
and all of it has brought me the same
thing
either i go to prison for more than five
more years
or i'm hooked on drugs really really
[ __ ] up and don't get me bad
i'm not looking like some hobo or some
bum on the streets but
i'm not looking as well up to par up to
par is where i mean where
everything is nice your shoes your pants
your shirt your hair everything's comb
right
and you're dealing drugs you don't mean
but like i said you know if you're a
real drug leader
then you have to be a real drug dealer
you can't sit on the corner and move 20s
and say you're dealing drugs because the
fact that
like i said i've seen them all i've had
my brothers my uncles my sister my
brother
all my family members have been through
their little drug thing
you know me either they were strong on
drugs or they were moving drugs and
sometimes drugs is so [ __ ] up where it
doesn't even matter if it's your family
member
even if your family member has a dope
and you're hurting and you need some
they're going to tell you no my family
members have shot me down many times
nah and i'm getting mad like what the
[ __ ] what do you mean you're my family
member you're not gonna leave me
sick are you hell yeah they would
because that drug becomes more important
than any than anything else and this is
straight from my family members you know
what i mean
and a lot of times i did the opposite
and brought my family members in
wrong thing wrong thing you don't want
to get involved with drugs and your
family at the same time
because your family member always has
that upper hand on you where they're
like well what about
they mentioned their kids or their old
ladies so you get that soft spot for
them
but now if you hire your enemy or
someone you really like
they're going to do their job to par
because they're trying to prove to you
that they can be the same place
you're at you know what i mean and i
learned that through the years of
being in a drug trade that you would
rather have your enemies some drugs for
you
than your closest friend because your
closest friend is always going to have
excuse
and your enemy is not going to look for
an excuse because they don't want to
look any weaker in your eyes
and i've had them both you know and i've
seen that before because
my homie's dealing for me i know his
wife and everything every time he would
come short with the money he would bring
his wife up
now she was sick with cancer so he'd
bring her up so i had that soft spot for
him
but yet i had a dude dealing for me that
i had beat up before
he was never late with his money he
never had an excuse
and i used to wonder why is this
[ __ ] never [ __ ] up
well what it was is he never wanted me
he never wanted me to see
him [ __ ] up or for him to ask me
for anything because he really didn't
like me but yet
that was the guy i wanted to keep close
to me you know like the guys i [ __ ] with
today
i got in a fight with him like two or
three times they either stab me or i
stab them
and they're the closest [ __ ] to
me right now some people would think man
that's kind of crazy
but no the lifestyle that i live i would
rather have a [ __ ] that i know
would stand up to me and want to fight
with me
than to have a [ __ ] on this side
that would bow down
to me and give me up when the time came
i would rather have the [ __ ]
that's
in the same spot with me i know that if
we get back to back and we're handling
our business that
i don't have to turn around and look for
this guy because he's right there
because he's not gonna let me
see him sweat get beat up or come short
and i learned that in the drug game you
have no friends
yeah you might be able to bump a
[ __ ] oh this is my dog
no he's not no he's not none of these
[ __ ] are your friends
you have no friends in the drug trade
you trust nobody
sometimes i can't barely trust myself
doing anything
you know why i speak about the drug game
is because
with gangs comes drugs there's never
just gangs and no drugs or drugs and no
gangs
no they run hand in hand maybe you want
to be that guy that picks up the sack
and get your sling on
and don't want to be involved in the
gangs it's impossible
because they're going to come and want
to know where you're dealing on their
street
and when they come you know they've come
a lot of times and asked me when i was
younger
hey we're here doing this this i'm just
living
i ain't living beyond my means
which means you know you're driving a
[ __ ] cadillac living in a shack
no i'm talking about they say sometimes
you know when i used to go approach
people and ask them about their drug
trade because i was in that seat to ask
them
i used to ask them but already know
exactly what they were doing
because i want to see what type of
person they they were you know if they
was to come out straight and tell me
look i'm moving announces i can give you
okay and that was what they were doing
well then most of them i wouldn't even
come i would miss a week with them every
month
just because they were honest in the
beginning but then you got those other
[ __ ]
oh i ain't got [ __ ] dog i ain't got
nothing and they're selling ounces
for five hundred dollars a whop and
they're moving like 15 a day you know so
you know you also run into people in the
drug trade like that
they act like they ain't got [ __ ] but
they got a whole lot of it
and then you know what really strikes me
the hardest inside is when people use
heroin
you just go to a corner buy a balloon
put in a cooker cook it and slam it you
don't even know what's
in that [ __ ] balloon you don't
even know if the dude put poison in
there
or if it's bad dope and it's gonna kill
you you know we never ever think of that
i remember so many times i grabbed stuff
out of people's hand and when he did it
without even checking it with it without
even seeing if it was good or
if it was bad you know once you put rat
poison in your veins you're dead i've
ran into many
many people and went to their funerals
behind them
overdosing on fattening or overdosing on
heroin or just getting a hot shot
but they were so easy to get a hot shot
because
nine out of 10 people would just grab
the dope out of hand
and go fix it without even knowing what
the [ __ ] actually is in there
you know i mean that it and it's very
very hard so drug game is very very hard
i would rather
tell you right now in front of camera to
get a job because the fact that
being in drugs is so hard it's a [ __ ]
hard ass job
first of all you gotta find the [ __ ]
second of all you gotta make sure it's
not bunk
third of all you gotta make sure the
dude ain't gonna burn you most of all
you're watching for the cops
you mean who knows how [ __ ] far you
went to pick it up
you might live all the way to normal i
can go all the way to pokemon to get it
it took you all day to go up and back
but
you want to be involved in drugs it's a
very very hard game it's
it's so hard that it just don't take
part to your mind it also takes parts of
your life
you know me and it cost me seven years
in prison one time
four years another time and to tell you
the truth all that getting high
didn't sum up to those four years i
spent in prison without spending time
with my kids or my family
i spent time in prison behind getting
caught with a 20 of glass
you know 20 glasses i wouldn't did seven
years where dudes were getting caught
with three guns and only getting five
years
you know i was like today if you go and
you get caught with a 20 glass
you know what they do they give you a
ticket and let you go right there on the
spot
but yet they gave me seven and seven
years of 80
for the same amount of drugs i got
caught with and they pat me on my
[ __ ] hand and said leave
you know so you got to be careful with
the drug game because
gangs are going to come with that and
you might not want to get involved with
the gang
but once you start selling that first
[ __ ] on the corner
you're only digging yourself a deeper
hole to where these guys are going to
come get at you and ask you hey
what are you doing how much you're
moving because you're on their block
they might not own it through the
government but yet that's their block
because they're on there all night and
day
and don't think you're just going to
sling and they're not going to come
you're going to get involved
i've seen many many many guys that stole
drugs and then i see them down the line
and they hit me up asking where i'm from
and i'm like wait the [ __ ] up i know
this dude is
and he's from a gang already how did he
get involved with that gang
behind the drugs and the money not
behind him going putting their work
because
they let [ __ ] in gangs now that
just make money foods that know how to
make money you got dudes out there
i ran into a guy that told me oh man you
got
guys that can kill you guys that make
money i'm the type of guy that makes
money
whoa okay i ain't [ __ ] with that guy
because
he left the other part out he ain't no
type of mother good [ __ ] you
know kelly hang on putting on work
he's just gonna make money so that means
when he gets thick
he's gonna give me up you know what i
mean and you got to watch that because
you know they got people out here
working for the police that all they do
all day long
is go buy drugs from people and then
tell the police where the drug spots at
and that ran into those people before
you got home girls out there that
they'll give you oral sex for five
[ __ ] dollars
you know so you know and it's it's
somebody's mother it's somebody's sister
it's somebody's wife you know me and
iran's and girls out here that
i'm kicking him and partying with him
and then somebody drives up in the car
and
he's balling everything he's talking
about hey nobody let this girl get hurt
because i'll come back and i'm looking
at like who is she i knew who he is but
who is she
a minute ago i was looking at her like a
piece of meat she's just out there
wearing us
giving [ __ ] oral sex for what but did
little did i know this is this dude's
little sister out there
now he's trying to get her to go home in
front of us she ain't going nowhere
she's stuck
she's stuck on the crystal meth she
ain't going nowhere she's not gonna
leave and
i remember when she got there oh man she
was beautiful
fine as hell now she's been there two
months and
her clothes barely fit her she's pulling
her pants up because she needs a belt
i remember when she was thick as [ __ ]
fine as [ __ ] no now i look at her
i wouldn't even touch her with anybody
else's [ __ ] you know i mean and it's
[ __ ] up because
that's what i've seen drugs do to people
for being out here for five years i've
seen
[ __ ] they go from here to up
here they're living in a tent
and then a year later they're up there
in one of those lofts that cost like
three thousand dollars a month
and they never ever come down again see
those are the ones that i trip on the
ones that
they're right there with you and then
they come up and make a step and then
they get
put up there in one of those lots and
you never see them again
you know they're up there because you
hear they're up there but they never
come down
and i always i always trip on that
because i go over there a lot and i'm
like hey what happened to so-and-so
he's up there what about switzerland
he's up there what they never come down
they never ever come down they stay up
there you forget they're around you know
meaning i just was asking one of my
homies recently
i thought he was busted all this time i
thought he was in jail no he's been up
there one of those lobs
and he doesn't move he doesn't come down
and put nothing in your hand he's up
there doing
the bigger things you know meeting up
there sitting watching all his [ __ ]
go on now if you get that high a more
more power to you but with being that
high
comes multiple multiple problems
because everybody wants to kick you out
that seat or everybody wants to sit in
that seat you have
no matter how much dope you move how
many people you had to handle
you're at a certain spot there's always
one or two [ __ ]
that want your spot they want your spot
and they're coming to get it no matter
what the cost is
whether it costs them their life or your
life they want your spot
now is it really your spot i mean how
did you make your spot you have to look
at
how long it took how many people you had
to have with you or how many people
fell through the way where you got your
spot
you have to remember along the way you
might made a lot of enemies
and along the way a lot of [ __ ]
are jealous they have envy
you don't mean they want to see you fall
you know you can get up to this high
and then they got that crab in the
bucket scenario
they're just going to pull you back down
you know i used to trip because there
used to be guys that tell me
oh man i'm getting out next week dawg
i've been down for five years as soon as
i get out
my homie's gonna put a pound of dope in
my hand and a strap
and that's your homeboy really ask
yourself
is that really your homeboy he didn't
say hey holmes here's the keystone
apartment
here's a card up you know get a job and
help me pay the rent
no he's here's a pound here's a gun
go ahead go back to jail now is he
really your homie
some guys might think that's my homie
dog he looked out tough
then you got the man on the other side
that'll say wait uh
this [ __ ] wants to see me go to
jail again because it doesn't matter how
much dope
he's going to give you he's giving it to
you for a reason most of the time he's
giving it to you because he knows you're
not going to get burned
you're not going to get got so if you
don't get burner you don't get got that
means he's not going to get burned he's
not going to get got
you know you think oh i'm the one doing
all the work yeah you are
he's just sitting up there collecting
the money you're bringing
and you're the one doing all the work
you think you're shining
no in everybody else's eyes he's shining
you're just helping him
keep shiny that's all you're doing you
know i used to think man i'm up here i'm
dealing pretty good
but there was always a [ __ ]
above me and
he was taking all the credit for all the
work i was putting in you know you have
to remember that
there's always levels to being involved
in drugs you got the user to the dealer
to the mover to the pusher you got the
[ __ ] food drops it off you got so
many
different levels of drug dealing that
people only think there's one or two the
guy who buys the guy who sells
[ __ ] no no there's levels
on everything it's just as you rise
higher in dealing drugs
you see what level there is because
you're on that level you just move level
by level
believe me at any given time you can
drop all the way to the bottom again
just for one [ __ ] decision you know
we make
thousands of decisions a day but only
takes one decision
to [ __ ] everything off you know and i've
known i've been to where i had
15 motels on whittier boulevard all the
way down winter boulevard 15 motels on
both sides of the street
i used to go drop off the dope
everywhere and then come back two days
later and pick up all the money
and i thought i was doing big things
hell no
the guy that i was picking it up from
and giving the money
now he was doing big things i was just
the one running around taking the
chances
what we call prison chances and you take
prison chances with dope
all the [ __ ] time you mean go ahead
and get caught with some acid
see how they break your ass off go ahead
and get caught with a lot of fentanyl
see how they break you off
when you can go with your id down the
street and buy some marijuana out of a
shop
for 30 40 bucks with your id this one
over here you got to buy
on the low low but this one you can buy
in front of everybody and walk around
with it a big old plastic
broadcasting that you got some marijuana
you know it's just
it's a real trip because i remember when
we used to hide smoking marijuana the
smell and everything we hide
you know me try to blow smoke away now
you can go
like it's the liquor store and buy
marijuana you know what i mean but yeah
you got guys sitting in prison doing
10-15 years
for a couple of pounds of marijuana when
you got these dudes over here making 10
15 000
for just pushing the [ __ ] out of a
dispensary they call it
you know and i've had a lot of
opportunities guys tell me come in man
come in just put your money in and we'll
get a dispensary going
i've seen so many dispensaries go down
i've seen dispensaries where
they're just there guy just gets a place
set up a gang of weed and he ain't got
no permission to do it nothing he's just
moving movie movie movie
boom until they crack them but everybody
in there knows if the cops come we're
busted
but do you want to work for me because
he's paying a good price
but yet if you get cracked all that but
that's there is going on you
and a lot of guys are willing to take
that chance me before i was willing to
take that chance when i was younger
because
jail didn't mean [ __ ] i'll go do it and
get right out but now that i'm a little
older
jail means just a little bit more to me
now because
before it was fun before you got there
and your homies had
tobacco and coffee soups for you and
everything everything you needed
now you go they ain't got nothing for
you all they're asking is what you
brought for them
the other way was the other way around
when you got to jail these to bless you
with everything
shoes clothes they eat the smoke
and it was all good now you can't even
ask a guy for a [ __ ]
top ramen which is 25 cents out on the
streets he'll have a problem just giving
you that
that's how bad jail has changed when i
went he used to be all older dudes with
big ass whips
tacked up slow as [ __ ] now i go
there's maybe like three or four older
dudes and the rest are all
youngsters shut the [ __ ] up dude's
trying to tell you amen you need to work
out today
and he hasn't even did a push-up in the
last five months you know that's the
kind of
morale that's the kind of people you got
in jail now they're
they don't they don't go by respect and
honor anymore
they go by how much money you got on the
streets
how fast you can get money to some of
these books you know
i just share that with you because i
wanted to share a little bit about the
drug trade it ain't all what it seems
before you take that step and want to
get involved in this [ __ ] like i tell
you all the time
do your homework first see what you're
really getting
involved with is it really worth it
because i'm gonna tell you before
anybody else
can tell you you're gonna lose your life
all your loved ones
your respect your honor everything goes
and gets tied up and thrown to the side
why
because drugs is more important a dude
would want to get his money before he
can want to help you
i just wanted to share that today you
know what that that's the drug trade
that
it about it all balls up to absolutely
nothing
it's illegal for one number two when you
get caught with it
the closest foods are going to give you
up the [ __ ] you thought had
your back
no they've been working with the cops
all along
so i share that today man if you're
getting involved in drugs do your
homework on it first
because you don't really want a part of
that [ __ ] i don't you know